are there no legalities about recording
people without their consent i don't
know how the law works in america
in the united states in 38 states it's
perfectly legal so so long as one party
is consenting what does that mean it
means that you know that i'm speaking to
you
you are with the person that is
recording you and if you think about it
that makes sense it's common law
um in america um if you are with a
stranger and that stranger records you
without you knowing that they're
recording your conversation well we
would believe that the recording device
is an extension of the pencil and paper
in fact in courts courts have made the
argument that society would not consider
reasonable an expectation of privacy
which would render a less accurate
version of the events in question
you have more of a right there
upton sinclair who authored the jungle
ran back to his apartment and wrote down
what he saw
but a written rendition of facts is
oftentimes not as accurate as a
recording of those facts so as long as
one party is consenting in other words
if you and i are at a bar
and i'm talking to you and i'm recording
you and you don't know that i'm
recording you it's legal now there's 12
states where it's illegal
like for example california uh maryland
pennsylvania unless
someone nearby can overhear us
we no way
if someone nearby is able to overhear
you then recording is permitted
in california we often do our journalism
in coffee shops
and in in some states like massachusetts
the law is so draconian oregon so you
can't even do that we have challenged
the constitutionality of those laws
again we believe recording someone that
you're with is a constitutional right
and again it's self-evident you can
write down what they say
no one's going to sue you for doing that
so we we've been very successful in
federal court in massachusetts we
overturned the law in massachusetts
project veritas did again another thing
that you did not know that's been edited
out of our wikipedia page we even
overturned the the law uh on the grounds
is unconstitutional
do you think do you struggle with it
ethically beyond the fact that there is
a legal precedent for you to be able to
record people if there are people around
to here or if one party is the one that
understands
do you feel like capturing somebody's
image their intonation the way that
they're talking about things when their
guard is down do you ever struggle with
that ethically
um yes i mean this this book
we struggle more with the ethics of what
we do than anybody of course the
ra the rub on us is that we're some
unethical scumbags who just go around
violating people's privacy but the
beauty and vein of ethics is that it's
inherently situational to quote jessica
midford who authored a book called the
uh
you know authored a book on muckraking
um and you know there's always
journalism is always going to harm
people information harms people
you know and the first amendment is the
first amendment to the bill of rights
and the constitution
because all other rights follow from the
first amendment so in a society that
places a primary value
on information that's unauthorized in
other words
i'm publishing information really
powerful people don't want published
you're going to harm people
good journalism harms people
um
but that's the that's the really the
what makes us american i think the the
values
codified in the bill of rights and uh in
terms of deception
on a hidden camera is not a form of
deception it's not a form of
eavesdropping because the person knows
they're being interviewed and it's not a
form of entrapment you have to go into
this realm of undercover work to get to
this whole idea of deception and there's
a whole chapter in this book called
deception i present the paradox of
relative deception which means
you have two choices you can deceive the
audience
or you can deceive your subject and
you're going to do one of these two
things and i would prefer to deceive my
subject such that i can tell the truth
to my audience
sorry james that only presumes that the
subject that you are speaking to would
speak untruths if they knew that they
were being recorded there is a situation
in which you could speak to somebody
right now mean you are having a
conversation i'm not trying to deceive
anybody neither are you so there is a
possibility that you can do the
recording without deception happening to
either party
this is correct and and this is what i
talked about with eric weinstein but
that presupposes that the person is
going to be more honest on the record
and i think it's a pretty fair
assumption that we were talking about
like pfizer pharmaceutical and the
department of justice and the pentagon
that these people are yes i'm a
journalist please tell me about all the
fraud you're committing i think it's a
pretty safe assumption that people in
the pentagon are not going to be honest
to a self-identified report of the new
york times and and then this chapter
called deception i i talk about this i
say you know you know that the leak
leaks right
uh someone in the near new york times
gets leaked documents
well oftentimes the leaks
usually it's not in the form of
documents actually it's the form of an
authorized statement from a two-star
general it's really a form of deception
because the person in power is usually
manipulating the journalist
and usually those leaks are authorized
leaks the information is is given to the
journalists consensually
so we want to do these things
non-consensually we want to do these
things without the permission from those
in power which does involve deception
towards the source not the audience
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you